au fil des ans le relais pour la vie
s'affirme comme un réel succès populaire
7000 participants l'an dernier 11000
cette année un défi et une récompense
pour les 200 bénévoles qui encadrent ces
24 heures de folie ce week-end 156
équipe de 30 personnes opus participent
au relais pour la vie
marcheurs du dimanche ou sportifs
confirmés cela importe peu
aujourd'hui c'est l'ambiance c'est de
courir pour une cause et puis c'est
aussi d'être en équipe on est nombreux
on est 80 personnes de la clinique
voilà donc c'est ça marche aussi en
termes de cohésion d'équipé on doit
faire deux heures aujourd'hui même si on
doit le faire on va rigoler on va
s'amuser même sur va le faire en
marchant doucement nombre indéterminé
ces deux heures même si on n'avait pas
fait en grand chose et on est là pour ça
fait vraiment plaisir en fait seulement
besoin de la forte affluence est une
bonne nouvelle pour la ligue contre le
cancer
chaque coureur vers ce 5 euros pour
l'inscription est une campagne de dons
est également en cours à l'accueil comme
sur internet
l'objectif cette année est de récolter
140000 euros pour boucler le financement
d'un espace bien-être ou les malades
pourront pratiquer une activité physique
adaptée ça projet de 500 mille euros le
premier c'était 750000 euros la maison
n'a qu'un suis là on a estimé à 500
mille euros et on fait tout pour le
réaliser l'année prochaine je revois la
ligue contre le cancer est heureux pour
le patient qui lutte contre le cancer
pour ce que nous appelons les survivants
dans le stade aujourd'hui ces personnes
malades ou en rémission arbore un
t-shirt survivants
pourquoi je me suis pas dessus et que je
suis là cette maladie n'y a pas eu
raison de moi pour l'instant dans des
moments comme ça vous vous voyez que
vous n'êtes pas seuls
est-ce que ça fait une différence oui
grande différence parce que par exemple
hier quand on a fait le défilé
d'ouverture
on a eu deux
des ovations d'aidé
les gens qui ont fait des colonnes comme
ça pour nous applaudir et en fait ça
fait quelque chose
saverdun des fruits sont 1500 nouveaux
cas de cancer sont recensés chaque année
en martinique pour aider les malades
l'appel aux dons se poursuit sur le site
relais pour la vie planète